the
teenager who's killing by a French
police officer was the Catalyst for days
of violence across this country
it passed from a funeral home to a
mosque and then to a cemetery on the
edge of the district when Naya was shot
there were two other passengers in the
car one was arrested the other escaped
he's now released an audio statement
claiming nael had been attacked by the
police officers and didn't mean to drive
off
the first officer at the window put a
gun to nayel's Temple and said don't
move or I'll put a bullet in your head
the second officer said shoot him the
first officer struck him again with the
butt of his gun the car is automatic and
was in park mode when nael received the
third strike of the butt of the weapon
his foot released the brake pedal and
the car moved forward and a second
officer who was at the windscreen fired
his weapon the signs of violence are
everywhere here this bus was used by a
charity now it's a wreck it was still
gently smoldering when we came across it
it's a really strange atmosphere here in
Monte today the streets are quiet lots
of people are distracted by the funeral
but what you do see are these the scars
of all that disorder and I think the
writers have felt empowered by the riots
we've been warned a couple of times we
were trying to broadcast and we're told
that we had to get out of there straight
away and what really strikes you is that
all day long I haven't seen a single
police officer president macron has
canceled his State visit to Germany his
interior Minister was out supporting the
police and trying to sound confident I
believe that the arrival of the 16
armored vehicles of the national
jean-darmory helped and especially gave
a new psychological shock it is the
Republic which will win it is not the
rioters
he said the violence was changing and
seemed less intense
but across the country there were images
of fires clashes and explosions
of cities and towns being ripped apart
more than 1 300 people were arrested
last night
police said officers in Leon have been
injured by gunshots Specialists Firearms
units have now been sent to that City
in Paris we saw Riot police arresting
youths who tried to loot a shopping mall
and the violence has even spread to
neighboring Belgium
this disorder is beginning to seem
Relentless and as the wave of
Destruction continues to build so you
wonder how it will be stopped Adam
Parson Sky News nonte